the minimalists want to help you avoid
impulse purchases that's why we created
five questions to ask before buying
which is now a wallpaper for your
smartphone
now you'll always have a reminder when
you're getting ready to purchase
something new
head on over to the minimalists.com
slash before
to download your free wallpaper today
[Laughter]
corey last question here recently
against my eternal love of books i
decided to get a kindle
to do my reading see this this question
presupposes that kindle books aren't
books
but they're literally e-books audiobooks
are audio books
and jokingly during the minimal often
say we'll give you the audiobook the
e-book or the book book
meaning the print book but they're just
different mediums they're all
books though i honestly prefer reading
on the kindle but sometimes i wonder if
i'll ever have a reason to hold a paper
book
again well i think we gave you sean and
i talked about the
the reasons the tactile experience but
bravo to you if you can go 100
kindle it's probably better for the
environment it's probably cheaper for
you
as well and so if you don't feel
compelled to have any print books i
think it's probably a better option
and i tried and for many years several
years i went 100 kindle and i found that
for some books i did miss the tactile
experience
in fact i had a new experience there's a
third or fourth way
you have print books you have audio
books you have ebooks
and then rob bell's book came out uh the
new one
everything is spiritual before his
publishers sent us the advanced copies
because
we got to read it before it came out
they sent me a pdf of the book
and i didn't want to read on just a pdf
on my phone because it's hard to read
and
i don't want to read a book on my
computer and so
i printed out the pdf
here at the co-working space that we're
at and i printed out the whole thing
two-sided and it's a long 330 page book
it might have been my new favorite
experience for reading a book because
here so i'm reading these pages like
this but it's a stack
but here's what i could do i could pick
up a stack of 10 pages
and so it's not weighing me down like a
heavy book or even like my kindle
um that's here's the downside to a
kindle
this book here that i'm holding how to
be here i just picked up a random book
this book will never run out of
batteries
this one does sometimes if i don't
charge it
so there are downsides to having a
kindle i think by and large the upsides
are far
greater and i enjoy ebooks slightly
better than
print books most of the time i probably
read most of my books
on an ebook but when i got rob bell's
book everything is spiritual
printed it out i was able to take 10
pages at once and just go
sit on the couch and then i'd flip
through them and i'd underline stuff if
i wanted to and
i put it back in my stack i'd pick up 10
more pages go over to the chair
uh read that for a little bit uh pick up
10 more pages
go to the dining room table and we
started this new ritual when we were
reading rob bell's book
right after dinner time me and ella and
bex we would just read
a few pages out loud of the book and
talk about some of the people in there
the lessons that we we learned and so i
think that's a beautiful thing about
books this is a great place to wrap up
here
is the shared experience that we have
whether it's with the author
with sharing the book with people that
we care about not thrusting upon someone
that's one of the worst things you can
do is say
hey you need to read this but when
someone come in
comes to you for recommendations and
you're able to
add value to their life you're able to
because then what happens afterwards i
remember the first time i shared
freedom with sean mahalik and
i started rereading it as he was reading
it the first time
and i'm texting we're texting back and
forth lines from the book and
this stands out to me this resonates and
i'm sharing this whole new experience
but in a different way all over again
or if i'm reading out loud to ella and
bex after dinner that's a
family experience or almost every night
bex and i we pick up a kindle book
and we read a chapter but i read it out
to her out loud until she starts falling
asleep she she starts twitching like
crazy
she like starts convulsing that's how i
know she's starting to to go to sleep
and it's like i'm reading her to sleep
it's a nighttime story right and the you
know we'll also read
stories to ella before you know as she
gets in bed we'll
pick out one of her books and read
something from the wild kratts or some
other children's
story that she finds value and she
enjoys and it puts her to sleep as well
and so it's more than just the solitude
solitary experience it's more than
solitary confinement
although books are great for that as
well but
it opens up a whole new world in the
real world for you
to share these experiences with other
people
and that's the opposite of clutter
that's that's real value
you